Thanksgiving is around the corner,
and to me, the holidays are all about giving back.
Lasagna Love is a great organization
where you can volunteer to share
a home cooked act of kindness, like this lasagna right here,
with someone in your community,
and they are partnering with LG,
who we are working with here at the show today.
I love lasagna so much,
because no matter how you prepare it,
the ingredients are just delicious, accessible,
and affordable.
I love the way they come together,
and I'm gonna show you a fun twist
to give your lasagna a brand new luck, maybe even fancy.
All right, here's how to make this twist.
Now, you're gonna take your cooked and drained noodles,
and you're gonna line them up just like so.
I'm gonna put some ricotta cheese mixture in each noodle.
You'll see that they have a little bit of herbs in there
to sort of bring that color, which is so important,
and it also adds that fantastic flavor.
And then you're just going to take it
and roll it just like so,
it's actually really easy and really fun to make,
and then, we're gonna line them up
and transfer them to a casserole dish,
sticking up vertically.
So then you're gonna spread
with meat sauce or marinara and mozzarella and bake.
This is a really fun dish to make,
there are so many interpretations of lasagna,
but I really, really love this one,
because we're always looking to reinvent the wheel.
I'm using the LG InstaView Range with convection,
which actually bakes more evenly and faster.
So I'm gonna preheat it to 375
and bake for about 45 minutes,
and then, I'm gonna come out with something
looking like this.
Now, it's that easy to get involved,
visit GiveLGLasagnaLove.com,
and sign up to be matched with someone
who could use a comforting meal.
LG is providing some amazing incentives to drew some good,
so you definitely wanna check it out,
me and my girls will be doing it too.
(upbeat music)